If I look at the value for me as A, between cooperating and defecting
in this first column. It's minus one versus zero, right? Which number is bigger?
>> [LAUGH], zero.
>> Right.
>> If I look at it in this column,
it's minus 9 or minus 6. Which number's bigger?
>> Negative six.
>> Right. In both cases, defecting is better
than cooperating. So in fact this choice, this strategy,
dominates the other. In other words it is always better for me to defect than
cooperate. So I will never cooperate, ever.
Because it's always better for me to defect.
>> So fine. So I'll never cooperate ever. That'll show you.
>> By exactly the same argument, minus
one versus zero, minus nine versus minus
six. Defecting is always better. B will
never cooperate. What's the only thing that's left?
>> Pain.
>> Pain. This is called the Prisoner's Dilemma.
>> Huh. You said it was simple, but it seems kind of evil.
>> I didn't say it wasn't evil. Those
things aren't opposite of one another. It's not like
perfect versus hidden. Or pure versus mixed. It's
not easy versus evil [LAUGH]. Evil's often actually easier.
>> It's easy and evil.
>> So we're in a little depressing place
here, Michael. You claimed in the beginning, and
I agreed with you, that this is sort of the best option,
you want everyone to cooperate, because that's sort of what's best for the
group. But because defecting dominates cooperating both for A and B you're going
to end up here. At least if you reason about it that way.
>> Yeah, I see that.
>> Hence prisoner's dilemma. The only way
to break this is if somehow we could
communicate and collude with one another. So
that we could guarantee that we would both
choose to cooperate at the same time.
>> So that wall? What about that wall? What if
you put a like a Skype connection or a Google hangout?
>> Well, if you were forced to say what you were going to say at the same
time, or somehow be able to punish someone
maybe for, you know not doing the right thing,
then you might be able to make a
different decision. But for this very simple version where
I'm going to do it once, even if I could hear what you had to say, if one
of us, whichever one of us went first, the second
one would always be able to take advantage of that.
>> I do find this kind of depressing.
>> Yes, it's a dilemma. It's a true dilemma. So, this brings us to a more
general sort of strategy. This whole notion of
strict dominance, works in this case. But, you could
imagine very complicated large matrces where it may
not work. But it turns out there's a
generalization of this notion of dominance. That works
remarkably well. And that's what people tend to use
to try to solve these kinds of games, to find out what the
true value of a game is. So letme describe that for you, ok?
>> Okay.